наша держава сплачувала До останніх днів
до липня 2023 року гроші за вироблену чи
не вироблено чи взагалі не існуючу
електроенергію сонячними
електростанціями на окуповані території
більше 300 млн грн і сьогодні на питання
А чи існують ці електростанції ми
відповіді не знаємо на питання якщо вони
існують Куди вони відправляли цю
електроенергію ми відповіді не знаємо
але ми знаємо відповідь на одне питання
А хто ж ці гроші отримав і це відповідь
ганебна Це родичі заступника голови
офісу президента Ростислава шурми його
рідний брат брат Олег Шурма інші
наближені особи друзі це ж ганьба
ганьбище під час війни просто викидаємо
віддаємо Гроші нам кажуть на військових
нема на це нема а просто вкрасти є
ганьба